what is up friends welcome to the new
Belle cave the new crib the new house
we are not moving from this place again
unless they offer me like three to five
times more than what I paid for because
I [ __ ] love this place I love it so
much
but guys
I'm so damn tired because last night it
was really cold I guess because techa
ended up sleeping on the bed so in
addition to all of this that's going on
today I had to move out of our apartment
because I'm turning
nice
uh returning that I'll play with you
returning that
um tomorrow as a matter of fact so I had
to like clean everything get everything
out so things were starting to look
organized and now they look
disorganized is book my bed I have to
steam it because I let tiger sleep on
that side
and that like it looks kind of a little
bit yellow there so I have to like steam
clean it that vacuum that sucks stuff
whatever that thing's called this I got
started yesterday but
I swear it feels like nothing ever
changes
my closet is I'm still in the middle of
it I was like cool all my shoes are
gonna fit not
to add some there here I have all my
heels that I haven't even included yet
so what I'm thinking I'm gonna do
because this is already a ton and my
clothes like
to start moving some clothes into
drawers because these are all empty
oh there's a lot to do
but honestly it's a lot of fun I just
wish I didn't have all my other
responsibilities like
this just kidding I love you so much all
right let's play so before I can get to
organizing again
um I have to play baseball with this guy
just in case you didn't know who he was
who are you
oh bark Juan taika yeah
and look at these pocket doors it opens
the entire way I didn't push it through
but yeah they go into this wall
so so do those
okay let's play okay we're gonna play
real quick
[Music]
now I'm ready
go back more that was really good I
didn't think you were that powerful more
I need to give you a smaller back
okay
that's powerful
I'll go
superheroes
go back go back you're too close right
there stop
good job
[Music]
we have ladder
that was epic it was epic
I don't even know what's happening at
this point check this out
foreign
[Music]
what is happening young man
[Applause]
what are you
taika the wet boy
pull it again
hahaha
isn't it cold out here yeah do you want
to watch me get wet sure okay
[Music]
isn't it cold
yeah
do you want to get wet nope one time
nope please nope
nope see you later
look at my cute Duty
I took a shower and everything all by
himself
we also have to do something about this
big ass couch
in our living room it's just way too
much couch so I think what I'm gonna do
is remove these two sections one two
sorry yeah three sections one two three
so clear this out move since this one's
already connected these two is connected
put this here so it's going to be this
up to
maybe there so that'll be the couch and
then I'm gonna get yay
go
I gotta have
bigger underwear for you
um seats here I might change this coffee
table to something round
maybe you get something here but I'm not
sure definitely getting a rug
maybe I won't get rid of that table it's
really cute when he jumps on it yeah but
yeah that's a lot of couch here okay in
terms of organizing
this has been my strategy and it's been
working
um because I just have to have my
surroundings be organized and clear and
clean and right now
anything but that
my stress levels are
through the roof so what I'm doing is
I'm just putting things in
a home a temporary home if you will so
anything in the kitchen I'm putting it
in the kitchen and I'm kind of think of
like workflow as best as I can and from
there I'm like okay then I start
strategizing and putting things where
they belong but I don't make it look
really pretty I've already added liners
because liners are the [ __ ] and if you
don't have liners you should add the
liners to everything that has any sort
of door drawers or cupboards of anything
that you want to preserve because
honestly Lifesavers and then I'll put
whatever belongs in there there even if
it's temporarily I still put it in there
just as a placeholder
and so things this isn't organized by
any means even though it looks really
organized but no
but for now at least I know my spice
rack will be there
and then I just have
other cooking things it's not organized
by any means I'm just throwing it in a
place for it to live so at least I know
where I can find stuff and continue
living my life
so that's been the strategy oh and I'm
taking these out of boxes like this this
is a air fryer if you don't have one I
highly recommend you get one but I have
two air fryers now
doesn't need to live in its home I know
everything about the airfryer so I'm
going to take that out just you know to
have space safe in space
what
you're just a party in your head what
song do you hear
[Music]
me
okay those underwear are just not
fitting anymore
all right all right I get it I get it
okay so I'm about
an hour or two in
things look a little bit more organized
yeah please please somebody yes yes
agree that it does I'm I'm on my liner
[ __ ] right now
um so I measure the cabinet
and then I line it up and then these
have like little bubbles so I just make
sure I create a straight line across the
bubble and then I cut it but I'm doing
this and as I'm doing this taika's
getting super creative here and he has
like a little train happening hello
yeah and he's designing what is this
what do you call this
is
my strong glass
oh drawing glasses
then and then I put them on of the
glasses then I'm gonna get some mama I
want to don't wear that
oh my God you almost got it in your eye
you got it on your eyebrow
s
more your eyebrow than your hair I could
see it
okay and what inspired and I'm looking
inside of it yeah what are you drawing
look how much marker I use on this yeah
does it mean anything
wow okay
that's really cool and like when you
ride your little tricycle then it's all
you're gonna pull all of this
and I like on the bottom you put what
did you put here protector so it doesn't
mess up the floor is that what you said
yeah oh who told you to do that
[Applause]
um
oh
oh that's a very very good
idea you had oh an attitude yeah good
job I love it
you having fun
nice
my duty
sleeping now
holy crap these last
like
maybe this last hour
and it's still a little bit intense let
me catch up on what the [ __ ] just
happened
so as you know I'm organizing
trying to impact
do you know the whole Spiel right
so psycho's doing his thing I showed you
his little creation
um you know
like I like to take breaks during all of
this especially when it's Papa's in
California well right now he's actually
in Texas
um I like to take breaks and then I like
to you know give him some quality time
and spend some quality time with him so
I realized I had already been packing
for maybe like an hour unpacking for an
hour or two now he was doing that and as
he was doing that I asked him oh that's
cute
laughs
I asked him hey dude did you want to
watch a movie before we go to bed and he
was like oh not yet Mom I'm not done and
I was like okay that's fine so I kept
them packing and in that he goes hey Mom
you want to do something funny and I'm
like yeah dude it was funny
you see this here
he puts one hand on so I'm on the other
side of the counter puts one hand one
here one here and he and he lifts
himself up
hey Mom I'm an adult now I'm so big I'm
like whoa dude you are big oh and he's
like doing this thing right now I'm like
oh okay I might be careful
so then um I just keep you know on with
my business
and he goes down and I just hear dunk
and he's like
man he's crying hysterically I'm like
holy [ __ ] and the first thing that pops
in my brain I'm like holy [ __ ] he's
split his [ __ ] mouth open or all his
teeth are gone and now he's bleeding so
I rush and I'm like I run my next to him
and then I'm like let me see your mouth
dude let me see her mouth and I was
expecting to see like a [ __ ] blood
bath luckily I mean it's still not that
lucky but he's bleeding from his tooth
but his teeth are still there so I'm
like fine and I'm like you know like
he's not bleeding profusely so I'm like
okay that's all so good and I look and
his tooth here
like is split like not down the middle
this way but like
like this is his front tooth if we turn
it this way
it's split like that like the front
enamel like broke off
I was like Wow [ __ ] I was like oh no
okay are you okay are you okay
and I'm like I don't know what to do
like I've never dealt with a dental
emergency before like what does one do
and it's after hours already like 7 30.
um his obviously his dentist office is
closed and I have to Google I'm like
five-year-old
um splits
split tooth what do I do
and it says okay like if it's not a chip
if it is if it's a minor chip leave it
alone it's fine if it's a major if it's
more than a minor chip you know take
them to the emergency room or an
emergency dentist I didn't even know
that they had emergency dentists there's
a few of them out here but I'm like I'm
just stick to what I know I'm just gonna
do Urgent Care uh because they were
saying like
we don't know how deep the
the split is or how severe it may be
so um
I go to urgent care and of course Urgent
Care is taking [ __ ] forever but
luckily I can sign in like online which
is super cool and fill out all that
paperwork and then they'll text me when
they're ready to see me
so then I wait like maybe 20 minutes
and he like he's still crying and he's
like oh wow and I'm like oh my God are
you okay and I'm like I don't know what
he's feeling so I don't know how
serious or severe this is but the fact
that it split this way
and there was blood between it I'm like
okay this ain't no normal [ __ ] chip
this is like a big deal
um so I finally get a text we go I drive
there
and then uh the doctor looks at him and
he goes you don't gotta worry about it
he's gonna lose his tooth anyways and
I'm thinking yeah [ __ ] but like
hello like is it hurting him he goes ah
just give him Tylenol if he complains
about pain and I'm like
okay you suck
but nonetheless
I really don't know what the conclusion
is my poor dude
this poor guy has been going through a
lot this year right like with seizures
and then he had bronchitis like two
weeks ago and now this thing and I'm
like man this fool is getting
[ __ ] up on all sorts of medication
this fool is gonna be a little [ __ ]
I don't know a [ __ ] medicine
connoisseur and [ __ ]
but the amount that he's been taking
these days
so now as I showed you he's sleeping and
he's comfortable
enough to sleep which is a good sign
right because I've had cavities and
those [ __ ] will not let you
sleep I was tossing and turning so that
at least tells me it's not as painful as
a
as a toothache so or like a cavity so
that's good and it's it's a relief but I
still need to make a a dentist
appointment for him
um just to make sure that it you know
yes he's going to lose excuse me he's
gonna lose his tooth whatever
but still like I still want the doctor
to check them out and and I want him to
conclude like okay we chilling you know
there's no further action just let him
go through the [ __ ] motions with this
busted ass tooth but God damn like this
[ __ ] happens so fast like in a blink of
a [ __ ] eye your whole life can change
like literally like maybe a few more
centimeters forward or backwards he
would have split and like [ __ ] I
don't know cut his entire mouth open and
now we're like stuck in the emergency
room and he's getting stitches and it
would just it would have been a [ __ ]
mess it's so crazy how quickly the tides
turn you know what I'm saying
man it's been a [ __ ] month like I'm
not one to look at things I need to sit
down because I'm about to get real with
y'all
perfect I know where to sit but maybe
I'll Lounge it out here
um
it's been a [ __ ] months like I'm not
one to complain about [ __ ] and I've been
through some [ __ ] like I've been through
a lot of [ __ ] before
um you know and I tend to be a pretty
private person and intend to be a pretty
positive person
I don't know what it is like this month
in particular there's been
so
much like heaviness around me
and I don't know if it's because now I'm
out here and I'm like completely
disconnected from like
my usual Outlets if you will like at
least you know when I was living in
California
when I was living in California I had
easier access to my friends and you know
my family and stuff
whereas now and I don't know if this is
it but whereas now I feel like I'm just
kind of stuck in like this
this like
like hamster wheel of like the same
thing day in and day out you know that I
I feel like it's weakened my
ability
to be Mega positive and feel very
uplifted and like
feel very inspired you know and I
understand that like you're not supposed
to feel like that all the time and
I'm not trying to say that I feel like
that all the time but whenever I do feel
any type of heaviness I'll feel it I
allow myself to feel it and go through
it and and just experience the human
side of things but I don't like to stay
in that emotion very long
um I don't see any benefit to it
for me personally and and um I always
try to find the lesson in anything
that I feel
um is like gut wrenching or
heartbreaking or
or just like any type of really heavy
negative emotion I really try to learn
from it and I try
um to take any lesson away from it so on
that note is what I mean
when I say that I'm a really positive
person but like this month in particular
talking about October wait oh [ __ ] we're
in November already Jesus Okay so
ber in particular and maybe maybe a few
months before then but October for some
reason just sticks out
a lot more to me
man it feels like
God or the universe or something like
I'm just excuse me like just being
tested like a [ __ ] like
I don't know everything around me feels
like it's kind of closing in on a little
bit like
like I feel like
there's a lot of loose ends everywhere
you know and I don't mean to be so vague
but like I mentioned in the previous
Vlog like
um you know we did have a really severe
loss in the family and it's something
that I can't
um I can't share
um not yet
but
that was pretty crazy and it shook us
all to our core
and then
yeah like it's weird like
I don't know this month just feels wild
you know so just this now happening
with taika and just even type of
seizures and stuff you know and
um
yeah it just feels it feels very surreal
you know and it feels like um
it's crazy because it's not even
happening directly to me you know what I
mean
and I understand like oh I'm obviously
feeling it because he's my son and it's
heavy and you know
you know as a mommy you always want to
protect your kids from stuff but
I don't know man I don't know maybe just
what's happening in the world and like
maybe social media is bringing me way
too much
like
realness you know like I don't feel like
I was exposed or you know I'm from the
generation where
we just had a few
news channels right and at least when I
was growing up those news channels seem
to be
kind of trustworthy and slightly
unbiased but I'm sure they've been
they've been pretty biased since I was
growing up but now it just feels like I
have so much access to so much
information
all at once and you get to see how
cruel Humanity can be and you get to see
like
just way too much man and like
I think that's also why I've like kind
of just stepped back from social media a
little bit because it just feels
so consuming you know and
like in a negative way and I know that
all of social media is not like that
like there's so many beautiful things
about it and I've met so many wonderful
people and I've made so many great
friendships from it you know and I'm
hello like I make a living from it but
I've made a living from it but
I don't know I feel like now it's just
so much
it's like too much
and I'm actually kind of just
workshopping this
with you by the way
um
I haven't really given this much thought
but just tonight like it was like this
additional thing that I was like whoa
what is [ __ ] happening you know so
I'm trying to like
analyze and be like why else can I
possibly feel this way so one of them
being like okay maybe I just don't have
access to my immediate friends you know
like my my tight Circle
um as I would you know if we were in
like California so that's one that I'm
thinking of right the other is oh and
I'm getting older you know and that's
like this other thing
um not something that I'm like
disliking but
I don't know for some reason I'm
thinking about it more and I don't know
if it's because I'm seeing myself look
older and I'm seeing my mom and my
family look older and my son like hello
we've all seen him grow up and he's
older now and I'm having conversations
so it's just like way more on my face of
like how fleeting time is you know
I didn't mean to get this deep yo but
yeah so that's like another thing I'm
thinking about
and I'm 39 by the way so next year I'm
going to be 40.
I do not feel my age and I love being
this age and like
I have
no negative feelings towards getting
older other than I'm seeing
time now if that makes sense
like I'm seeing it like I see my like
maybe you guys are you've seen it you
know and you're like duh [ __ ] like what
are you talking about but I just I I
wasn't there you know now that's more at
the Forefront of my mind so there's that
Nevada living out here alone was the
other thing oh like everything in the
world just feels really [ __ ] up and
now you have like Kanye going on he's
[ __ ] weird ass Rants and then you
have the [ __ ]
um
what is it
Maxwell Delaney [ __ ] trial and she
got she's guilty for some [ __ ] and like
we don't know we don't know uh who these
other parties that she was [ __ ]
Distributing these [ __ ] girls
children to are like okay we don't get
any of that like there's just it's so
[ __ ] weird you know and now they're
like
huh I don't know man it feels [ __ ]
weird and I try not to contribute to
that because I know we're all dealing
with [ __ ] I know we're all struggling I
know
you know we all carry some heavy [ __ ]
[ __ ] on our back you know and we're all
given the loads
that this [ __ ] Universe thinks we can
handle
so I never try to be one
that contributes to your load if that
makes any sense you know and I know that
there's people out there that are really
good at being open about sharing you
know their loads and stuff
and and good for them that's just not
who I am I've never been that person
um I don't like having that energy
around me and not to say that it doesn't
exist because
we all literally I mean again it's part
of the human [ __ ] experience like we
all have it but that's just not
the vibe
I ever try to put out there if anything
I always want the vibe to be like
hey I'm here for you and I want to have
a good time and I want to philosophize
and I want to
question things and I want to [ __ ]
around and I want to make jokes you know
like that's that's my coping mechanism
for things you know
um having heart to Hearts joking around
doing all that stuff
so like even making this video I'm like
it's not really my style what I'm saying
but yeah I just have to be real man like
this is the first month
that I felt like God damn
[ __ ] that [ __ ] feels off
and and maybe you're feeling it too you
know and maybe now we're connected where
it's like we don't normally feel this
way but some [ __ ] is Shifting something
is happening and it's
and it feels pretty uncomfortable you
know
but
just hearing myself say that
the light at the end of the tunnel
because I'd like to stay [ __ ]
positive and uplifted as often as I can
is
the light at the end of the tunnel this
[ __ ] doesn't last forever and and the
fact that it feels so [ __ ] off
tells me
that yes maybe it can get worse but
that's not what I'm holding on to
tells me that there's an upside it's
gonna happen you know or it is happening
and I'm just not paying attention to it
because hello
I'm in a new [ __ ] house
that's a [ __ ] upside right
ah
yeah
what's that saying
um there's always a rainbow
at the end of rain
something like that right but yeah just
wanted to have a little real real with
y'all
and just be like yo again this [ __ ]
feels off and I do not know why
but I'm looking forward to it just being
a [ __ ] Coast
so
what I'm gonna do instead of waiting for
this Coast to happen is
yeah
one I need to write more because I
haven't been doing that and like
whenever I feel kind of Funkadelic in my
[ __ ] brain or in my feelings I write
all the [ __ ] million things that are
happening in my head I write it out and
I'm like oh relieved because it feels
like I got some [ __ ] sorted
um
so that and then just focusing again on
all the good
because yeah there's been
maybe there hasn't been a bunch of no
there for sure has been actually it's
been [ __ ] gnarly
um so yes it's been gnarly but just yeah
I got to tell myself you Geo
really fight hard to find the beautiful
in all of that
and I know this
but I think I've been slacking
ah
again
so if you're going through some funky
funky phases right now
You Are Not Alone
because so am I
but what we're gonna do because we're
not [ __ ]
do nothing about it and let life happen
to us type of people
we're the type of people that make life
happen for us
we are going to sit down write our
thoughts out
not give a [ __ ] about grammar how pretty
it looks just right right right right
right
and try to find the lesson in all of
those negative things that we see
and then we pursue
the positive relentlessly
all right
so um yeah it looks like the night's
kind of ending for me
because I'm just gonna let this dude
sleep
ordered him some udon
sorry I moved on so quickly but I think
I just closed it I was just like yeah
that's what I'm gonna do and I'll be
doing too but moving on
yeah or to do this dude some udon
because I want to just kind of see the
sensitivity of his tooth one two if it
is sore because he did just [ __ ] bang
it on the counter I don't want him not
to chew on it even though you don't
really chew with your front teeth anyway
I just didn't want to bite on anything
so I got him some udon I feel like it's
gonna feel
you know nourishing from the inside out
[Music]
um
all right so my battery died last night
and then since with living out of boxes
I couldn't find this cord to charge it
oh my God are you okay
hey how's your tooth today
a little bit or a lot
ew I totally missed it I'll be right
back
being a mom never as anyway but what I
wanted to say was yeah um
it died suddenly but yeah I just wanted
to share that because you know I'm not
one to ever share stuff like that just
because again I feel like there's just
so much of that already in the world and
and we're all you know carrying our own
bricks on our back that I'm like why am
I gonna add mine to yours when mine are
probably one not as heavy as yours two I
don't need to put it out there
um if anything whatever I do want to put
out there I want it to be very
empowering and I want it to be you know
very positive and enlightening
um so even with this I'm like if you're
going through something
hey
it just it feels weird and I'm saying
um but I don't want it to get twisted or
mixed up I'm doing absolutely great I'm
participating in this whole Human
Experience and I am feeling all of the
emotions
um but if I were to zoom out big picture
wise I really have nothing to complain
about so
being grateful every single day I'm
healthy I have a wonderful husband a
wonderful son wonderful family in-laws
I'm blessed beyond belief
but um again like I said if you're
feeling off don't worry I'm feeling it
too so until tomorrow have a beautiful
day stay blessed count your blessings
and kiss everyone that you love
bye oh love you